Here's something interesting and also kind
of sad.
Uh, CNBCS Joe Kernan attacked me as a socialist
on Twitter the other day and this actually
relates to a bigger picture thing that's going
on.
Um, when I was 15 years old, I started paying
attention to political news and business news
and financial news.
And, uh, I started investing a little bit
of the money I earned circuit city where I
worked in, in high school, I started watching
CNBC and CNN and reading newspapers and political
magazines and reading old investing books
by Ben Graham and by others and just learning
about this stuff.
And in doing that, I got to know a lot of
who the news people were at the time.
And sadly now as an adult who's working in
news media, I've gotten a chance to meet or
interact directly with a lot of these people.
And I am so disillusioned with a lot of them
that I can't believe that I ever thought,
um, uh, that had great things to contribute
when I was a kid.
I mean, maybe they did at the time.
So like one example is I never met her in
person, but I used to respect Maria Bartiromo.
Okay.
When Maria Bartiromo was on CNBC, she was
the first woman to report from the floor of
the stock exchange.
Very interesting.
I saw her as a strong interviewer who would
come confront corporate CEOs with tough questions
and deliver financial news in a business that
was so dominated by men at the time.
She now has a show at Fox business network,
has completely jumped on board the Trump sycophant
brown noser train.
And she truly discussed to me like, it's just
sad what has happened to Maria Bartiromo.
Someone else that I used to admire, who I
now know personally, and I'm hugely disillusioned
with it.
Scott Adams, the creator of the Dilbert cartoon.
When I was growing up, I loved the Dilbert
comics.
I read all of them.
I read some of Scott Adams books.
I thought that the comics were hilarious.
Uh, uh, in terms of being commentaries about
corporate culture, I found the books interesting.
I've now interviewed Scott Adams multiple
times.
Sometimes we direct message privately on Twitter.
And as I've told him publicly, it's become
a huge disappointment.
I mean a childhood disillusionment to see
him become this staunch defender of Donald
Trump.
Really, really sad.
And there's now another person we can add
to this list list and his name is Joe Kernan
from CNBC.
Joe Kernan has been on CNBC.
Yes, since I was a 15 year old and started
watching business news.
He's a guy in his early sixties who's been
with CNBC since 1991 I don't want to pretend
he was ever a hero of mine, but similarly
to to Maria Bartiromo, I grew up watching
him interview corporate CEOs and the whole
thing.
And I already started to look at Joe Kernan
very skeptically when he was on a panel interview
with a former Facebook executive a year or
two ago.
And he was asking like the dumbest and most
uninformed questions about social media and
social networks.
And I thought, man, Joe Kernan might have
no clue what the hell he's talking about.
And it is now much worse because over the
weekend and late last week, he got into an
argument about whether CNBC is now jumping
on the climate science denying train because
of an interview that he did related to climate
science or something.
I ended up getting tagged into this Twitter
thread about it and Joe Kernan tweeted something
so ridiculous about carbon dioxide, which
has become a popular talking point on the
science denying, right?
That carbon dioxide is great because plants
need it to breathe.
We breathe out CO2 and plants breathe in Sio
two so more co two is great for plants, which
of course ignores all of the science around
this and it ignores the idea of an ecosystem
in balance in the same way that listen, humans
need water in order to live, but at a certain
point, too much water becomes bad for us,
right?
The same sort of logic applies to carbon dioxide.
So then Joe Kernan shows up and tweets in
this thread that I'm in.
You do know humans excuse exhale 100 times
the concentration of atmospheric co two ever
had a coke be careful laced with poison, which
is just so dumb.
And I responded dam to think.
I used to watch Joe on CNBC when I was a kid
growing up, depressing and sort of surprisingly
Joe Kernan responded to me and said, yet you
still grew up to be a silly millennial socialist.
That is depressing, which of course is number
one using a socialist as an insult.
But more importantly, I am not a socialist,
which I told them saying, Hey Joe, I'd love
for you to present one shred of evidence that
I'm a socialist.
And of course I never heard back.
So when this stuff happens, yeah, like it's
depressing on a personal level to see these
people out themselves as toxic fact, free
science, denying ideologues.
And it's also just depressing that I used
to actually look up to some of these people,
not ideologically, but in terms of their kind
of place and role in the media sphere and
some very basic sense.
And it turns out that they are truly horrible
people contributing to the weaponization of
ignorance that has become endlessly prevalent
in the era of Trump.
So I guess someone, someone else on the list
that now uh, is going to be seen very differently
by me and probably by, by much of my audience,
although my guesses, my audience probably
already had a far more negative view of Joe
Kernan than I did before these tweets.
Let me know what you think.
Makes sure you're following the show on
instagram@davidpakmanshowandfollowmeoninstagramatdaviddottaxthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com